اهلا وسهلا على مدار رمضان رافقكم تفاعلكم
في موسم استثنائي من كل النواحي اولا لانه
لاول مره طلينا عليكم لمده ساعه كامله على
الهواء مباشره وثانيا بسبب موعدنا الرمضان
اللي هو 12 بتوقيت السعوديه واللي بنطل
عليكم فيه اليوم لاخر مره في هذا الموسم
قبل ما نرجع لموعدنا المعتاد اللي هو سته
مساء وثالثا لانه حقيقه كان موسم درامي
استثنائي وغني ومختلف ومليء بالاعمال
الضخمه وبالجدل كمان ومثل كل سنه تفاعلكم
راح يختم معكم حلقات الموسم الرمضاني
بحلقه بنسميها احنا بيننا وبين بعض في
فريق العمل جردت الشهر فخليني معاكم
اعزائي المشاهدين بنجرد هذا الشهر وانا من
كم ثانيه كنت بقول لكم انه كان في موسم
حافل بالاعمال الدراميه نتكلم عن عشرات
عشرات الاعمال الدراميه وهذا الدليل
بسم الله نبدا الموسم سر الباتع من في سر
الباتع وفي مسلسل سر الباتع وسر الباتع
ايش العوده من مسلسل المتمرد في سفر كتبه
ابريل رساله الامام الى رساله الامام
رساله الامام استوديو 23 وسقط سهوا سوق
الكانتول مسلسل عمله نادر عمله نادره
وعمله نادره صندوق عشره عمر فهو مسلسل
دفعه لندن الدفعه لندن دفعه لندن دفعه
لندن دفعه لندن دفعه لندن الصفاره عود
سخيه للنار بالنار مسلسل النار بالنار
والنار بالنار والهرجه السابعه في الهرش
السابعه او مسلسل واخيرا بين صبايا وجلطه
مسلسل الاشهر منه ولدنا اثنين وفي منه
ولدنا اثنين وجعفر العمده جعفر العمده
جعفر العمده مسلسل جعفر العمده الى جعفر
العمده في جعفر العمده وبين العمده
والصندوق مسلسل قط احمر عن الزند بالعاصي
وصفر في حياه المثاليه مسلسل النون وما
يعلمون مسلسل ضرب نار ومسلسل ستهم ستهم
بستهم تلت التلاته الف الف حمد لله على
السلامه
كل هذه الاعمال اتكلمنا عنها وكثار من
نجومها نورونا كمان في تفاعلكم السنه
نورنا فيها اربعه واربعين نجم ونجمه هذه
تحيه منا لهم جميعا
وينضم الينا النجم احمد فهمي العروس مريتا
النجم خالد المظفر الفنانه ميلا الزهراني
كل عام وانت بالف خير ماجد النجمه هند
نزار فيكي معانا ما يفن نجم احمد عبد
الرحمن اليماني الفنان هشام عاشور الممثله
رولا عادل شكرا لك يا ابراهيم المخرج
الكبير خالد يوسف الفنانه ليلى عبد الله
النجم المخرج محمد سامي من بيروت النجمه
ورد الخال النجم القدير محمود البزاوي
نجمه روجينا ادم الشرقاوي الاعلام العراقي
احمد البشير اهلا فيك معانا يا احمد ناصر
الدوسري اهلا فيك معانا يا ناصر شكرا لك
يا هاله على وقتك اليوم الفنان طوني عيسى
اهلا فيك معنا ميونه وحشتيني الشاعر
الممثل نقول الان هشام نجمه جاني اسبر
الفنان فايز بن جريس الفنانه ناهد الرباعي
النجمه اسماء جلال الاستوديو من بعد طول
انتظار النجمه على المطاوع اهلا فيك يا
حنان النجم جورج
احمد شاهين اهلا فيك معنا يا غاده النجم
محمد شاهين النجم الكبير جمال سليمان
الفنانه جوري
يا حبيبتي الله يسلمك
الكبير عبد الله
المخرج النجم محمد سامي اهلا فيك يا محمد